if I can start with you professor what
is the point at which you think one of
the big sponsors coke or McDonald's
would actually feel that it needed to
dissociate itself from FIFA well I think
if it if it continued to be the case
that FIFA denies any systemic wrongdoing
and doesn't undertake a systematic
restructuring of the organization I
think they might have to have to rethink
it but these brands have held on for a
very long time in the face of a lot of
evidence of wrongdoing so I'm not
totally convinced that that anything
very much is going to kick them out well
suppose Sepp Blatter is reelected
tomorrow would that be the point no I'm
not I'm not committed that it is I mean
they know said Blatter they know him
over many years they know what kind of a
man he is nothing that came out in the
indictment yesterday was really big news
to anybody who follows football and so
coke and visa could have taken this
action taking that action many times
before and had balked at it so no I
think if he's re-elected I think they
will re-evaluate they will question they
will make some public statements but I
think they're likely to stick with FIFA
so is that like I mean what that means
is in spite of the contempt for the
organization widespread in major markets
in Europe and North America these
organizations still think it's to their
benefit to be associated with the World
Cup yeah I would have expressed their
concern but ultimately it's the people's
game and I think that's going to be a
really key factor in what they're trying
to reach is the people in the game so
the question is could you imagine the
FIFA World Cup not happening probably no
in which case there's a huge audience
there which is just going to lap it up
so there's an element of is there some
way shape or form that you divorce the
government side of it with the actual
competitive side ultimately no but
nonetheless the game is what they're
really about and that's what they've got
to focus their efforts or what well the
game is what the sponsors are about is
about selling the product are they yeah
but they're about an association with
football and through that and that
access to that audience I mean we've
already seen professor haven't we some
pretty
odd things happening like there's a beer
Budweiser sponsoring the Qatar Games
where beer drinking is not something
widely encouraged that's right again
part of this is it's about it's mostly
about television mostly people consume
the World Cup through watching it on TV
and those few weeks every four years are
incredible magnet for exactly the people
that these sponsors want to reach and
that's why they stick with it and
everything else they can take a lot of
pain elsewhere just to have that big hit
every four years we have seen
organizations involved in football
you've advised the FA in the past I mean
it is an active possibility you say well
can we think of the World Cup not
happening I could think of UEFA for
example pulling out the World Cup but if
it continues like this can't you mmm I
don't think so no I think they've
already said a lot of people beginning
to voice you know the kid is the
people's game that's what people are
about this will happen and what would it
really achieve only weird sort of voter
protests rather than an active
development what really needs to perfect
is what everyone's talking about there
needs to be that root and branch change
and culture and structure and approach
towards the game and you've got to look
at people like Thomas back and Brian
cooks and and various others who are
really taking up strong change cultures
now if Blatter's re-elected the question
is can he then really introduce systemic
change credibly with authenticity and
actually pull that through
say what within one two years otherwise
he's going to leave under this cloud and
no one's going to believe it's ever gone
away if he's not well then again there's
that opportunity for root and branch
change what do you think professor I
mean because UEFA is really well
football I mean the best teams all come
from Europe with past Brazil is an
exception I mean if they pulled out the
World Cup would be rubbish wouldn't know
so why don't they do it well it would be
but one thing is Oh Russia is part of
UEFA for a start so they're not going to
want to pull out of their World Cup
that's not going to happen
I think there are many associations they
many other associations in Europe that
have strong connections to Blatter maybe
not the Northwest European ones but
maybe some of the other ones who
wouldn't want to walk away from him and
do they really want to be seen to the
Europeans want to be seen to be the ones
who tear the game apart this is
extraordinary situation we have a so
called people's game costing the people
a lot of money and apparently you know
Riven with moral turpitude of how to
quit learning well there's a big sports
as a whole as a crossroads what you've
got is you've got old-style governance
coming through volunteers committees all
that sort of strategy and then you've
got big money coming in so you reach the
point where arguably the business is a
lot bigger than the structure can handle
right now this is one of the sports is
at that point where the old government
structures need to move towards much
more savvy business practices much
better regulation self regulation self
management to make sure that they're
doing the business arguably as
professional as the players are on the
field of play you know making sure that
they're putting you've got the best
executives the best players the best
advice and the best systems all the way
through because you're dealing with
billions of dollars here and you know if
you don't have that experience in
business then is there not a question of
whether there's bound to be the old fall
out here and there